- Hi. My name is Grace Hwang
and I'm an educator here
for school programs.
For a student that hasn't really
been introduced to modern art,
I think this painting can
be a little bit challenging.
Usually for students, I try
to break it down for them,
to see that Picasso here
is really interested
in taking a human body
and translating it into
colors and shapes.
Your eye starts to look for
things that are familiar,
like oh, I see a face, I see some eyes
and then slowly, these different shapes
kind of come together and then, you see,
like there's this mirror
and I think that's really interesting,
that moment of discovery for them
when they're like,
"This is a girl and she's
looking at the mirror
"and the mirror is telling her
"something different from real life."
She looks really sad or she
doesn't like what she sees
or it's showing her her true emotions
and it's really exciting because
that is a direct
interpretation and I ask them,
"Well, how did you get there?"
Ya know, we start
talking about the colors.
They're so dark.
Her eyes no longer have pupils.
They're sort of sunken and deep set.
The discovery that I've made
in just studying this painting
is the background, this crazy
diamond and circle pattern,
of it being a harlequin pattern
and knowing that Picasso himself,
thought of himself as like
a trickster or a harlequin.
And so, that the background
is a metaphor for Picasso.
When the students can go there,
I'll offer that bit of information
as a discovery that I've
made myself through research
and it's just really interesting because,
you know, maybe for some kids,
they're like, "That's too out there.
"That's crazy. I'm just
gonna stick with like,
"this is the girl, this is
how she perceives herself,
"and that's what it means for me."
And then some people will be like,
"Oh, this is how Picasso
perceives this woman,
"young woman looking at
herself in the mirror."
What I love about art,
especially modern art,
is that it meets you where you are.
Like, if you're ready to go there,
it'll invite you to come in.
And if you just wanna
keep, stay where you are,
it'll say, I'm with you there too.